- My name is Jackie Delamatre.
I'm a School Programs Educator
here at the Museum of Modern Art.
And this piece is by Frida Kahlo.
It's called Self-Portrait
with Cropped Hair.
I really like to teach
from this object because
to me, the conversations
here really unfold
like a story, a series of observations
that lead into further interpretations
until at the end, we're
delving into this whole area of
feminism, what is beauty,
of a question of a woman's
place in the world.
What usually happens is they're noticing
who is this person.
They're starting to
think about the clothing.
They're thinking about the hair.
They're thinking about
the facial structure.
the earring they can see.
And their main questions
to themselves are,
"Is this a woman or is this a man?"
And then we start to see and
notice the hair on the ground.
And then they start to see
the scissors and they say,
"Actually, maybe this is a
woman who cut-off her hair."
But not only is it a woman
who cut-off her hair,
it's a woman who's wearing a suit,
so then it brings up another question:
"Why is she wanting to look like a man?"
That's usually how they phrase it.
Then, what it comes to is the top.
There are musical notes there
and they're in Spanish.
And it says, "Look,
"if I loved you, it was
because of your hair.
"But now that you are without hair,
"I don't love you anymore."
One reason that I think this
piece is really relevant,
really exciting to students,
is the fact that this is something that
they're dealing with in their
social lives all the time.
People are not necessarily
just going to like them
for what's on the inside and
feeling the unfairness of that,
the injustice of it.
So, in this case, not
only the injustice of
somebody having said, "I only
loved you for your hair,"
but also the injustice of
what it was like to be a
woman artist at that time,
to be married to somebody who had
so much fame and so much
success as a male artist,
and really having to wait posthumously
to get the fame and the
love and the respect
that Frida Kahlo now has
and I think really deserves.